[EN]  because i know you asians love quizzes so i'm going to give you a quiz i'm going to ask seven
[EN]  questions from this morning's lectures okay now if you raise your hand you can refer to your notes
[EN]  or you can look in your booklet for answers but if you get a question right you can have a book
[EN]  i'll give you a book are we ready are we ready okay so raise your hand here's the first question
[EN]  okay in this morning's presentation in my presentation presentation i said there were
[EN]  eight critical skills every person needs can someone name two of those critical skills go ahead
[EN]  personal responsibility yes and uh resilience resilience excellent give her a round of applause
[EN]  Okay, well done. Question two. Are you ready for question two? Okay, in the same lecture, I said, there's a certain process you have to go through to develop skills. There were five steps in that process. Oh, she knows.
[EN]  Okay. Can someone name at least three of the steps? Brilliant. Round of applause. Excellent. Okay. In Drew's Clinical Excellence presentation, he mentioned that there are six parts that make a complete assessment.
[EN]  clinical wheel can you name five parts of the clinical wheel you guys you guys
[EN]  true was worried that nobody was listening to it but you clearly were
[EN]  that's brilliant okay next question okay in
[EN]  the professor's lecture he talks about community psychology can somebody tell me
[EN]  what community psychology is excellent well done well done okay two more
[EN]  questions two more books who can name at least two sections of the processing
[EN]  approach
[EN]  that you should be an expert way of being flexibility yes Linda gets the book
[EN]  okay last question Drew taught us today about the six common symptoms that we
[EN]  see in a neurodiverse or processing student when we use the word neurodiverse
[EN]  and processing, they're synonyms. You can mix them. Can you tell me at least three of
[EN]  the symptoms that are common in a neurodiverse student? Three symptoms that are common in
[EN]  a neurodiverse student. We just heard this lecture. Yes? Rigidity. That's one. Give
[EN]  me another one. Emotionally dysregulated. Give me one more.
[EN]  Is that a funnel overflowing? Maybe it is.
[EN]  Yes, disorganized. Well done, well done. Okay, brilliant. Thank you. Round of applause.
[EN*]  Okay, welcome, Barry.
[EN*]  I have no clue what she said.
[EN*]  Okay, so Drew, in his presentation today, he kept mentioning the word telos.
[EN*]  Because telos is where we work.
[EN*]  And there isn't a place like telos in Taiwan.
[EN*]  So I invite you to get on board with a plane with me to visit telos.
[EN]  so I want everyone to close their eyes, everyone close their eyes, close their eyes, fasten your seatbelts, everyone fasten your seatbelts, please relax and enjoy the flight as we land in Oromuta, open your eyes, and welcome to Tilos, welcome.
[EN*]  Okay, so when most people hear the phrase residential treatment, they imagine teenagers sitting in therapy all day.
[EN*]  That would be terrible. That couldn't be further from the truth. Residential treatment is really about living life.
[EN*]  Every hour, every meal, every classroom, every friendship, every success, and every failure.
[EN*]  Becoming part of the treatment process. Today, I'd like to take you on a tour of TELOS. Now imagine you are a 16-year-old boy. Let's spend a week together. What would that look like?
[ZH] 每一次的成功,每堂課,每一次的吃飯,每一次的失敗挫折都是一個復原歷程核心一環
[ZH] 所以我今天就想帶大家來參觀一下T-Low是怎樣的一個環境
[ZH] 大家先想像一下你自己是一位剛抵達T-Low Seagull的16歲青少年
[ZH] 我們接下來要在這邊一起度過一週的生活
[ZH] 除了Blinda,有人曾經在Yuta嗎?
[ZH] Yuta?
[ZH] 你記住嗎?
[ZH] 有人去過猶賀州嗎?
[ZH] 我們近來的沿岸市
[ZH] 我們這裡的沿湖,這裡很近
[ZH] 對,我們要花一個日子的治療
[ZH] 我們先開始談談的時間
[ZH] 我們要問一個問題
[EN]  And why doesn't it exist in Taiwan yet?
[EN]  Because outpatient therapy isn't enough for every adolescent.
[EN]  Some teenagers struggle everywhere.
[EN]  At home, at school, with friends, with authority, with emotions, and with family.
[EN]  If every environment is contributing to the problem, then every environment must become a part of the solution.
[ZH] 在代理大家參觀,我們要先回答一個問題,就是為什麼這種全日型的住宿是有存在的必要,特別是在臺灣我們還沒有看到有這樣的一個住宿機構
[ZH] 那答案是因為對某些青少年而言
[ZH] 每週一次的門診心理治療
[ZH] 已經不足以符合他們的需求了
[ZH] 因為有些青少年面對的掙扎是全面性的
[ZH] 他們在家就是跟家人衝突不斷
[ZH] 在學校適應不良
[ZH] 在朋友之間受到挫折
[ZH] 那在跟體制裡面是對立抗拒的
[ZH] 然後情緒常常失調
[ZH] 然後各方面的系統都面臨崩潰
[ZH] 所以當個案身處的每一個環節
[ZH] 每個環節都在加劇問題的時候,每個生活環境都必須被轉換成解放的一部分。
[EN*]  Now, before a student ever arrives at TELOS, there's usually a long story behind the referral.
[EN]  Now, our referral sources generally come from four places, does that look familiar?
[EN]  Familiar with this? Maybe in the classroom? Maybe at home?
[EN]  Now, the first referral source, we call them private educational consultants.
[EN]  Our largest referral source is the private educational consultant market.
[EN]  Now, these are professionals who work with families to help them navigate educational and therapeutic options for their children.
[ZH] 每一個學生的背後通常都會有一段很漫長的故事
[ZH] 我們的來源有四個途徑
[ZH] 第一個是私人教育顧問
[ZH] 這是我們最大的來源
[ZH] 這些顧問他們是專門協助家庭去梳理他們的教育還有治療的資源
[EN*]  They will prove the best for the children's children.
[EN*]  Our second largest referral source are school districts, particularly in states such as Illinois or California.
[EN*]  In certain circumstances, when a school district cannot adequately accommodate a student's educational needs within the state, the district may fund an appropriate out-of-state placement.
[EN*]  These districts become important partners in helping identify students who require a more comprehensive educational and therapeutic environment.
[EN*]  The third major source is other treatment programs, which includes wilderness programs, psychiatric hospitals, acute care settings, and other therapeutic programs.
[ZH] 我們的第三個主要是其他診療程式
[ZH] 這包括育館程式、醫療醫院、患者醫療程式
[ZH] 以及其他診療程式
[ZH] 這些公司常常知道我們的診療程式
[ZH] 我們知道他們好
[ZH] 而若一人完成了急程度的治療,但仍然需要一個整個住宅環境的環境,這些治療夥伴侶推薦Telos進行接下來的步驟。
[ZH] 結束了急性治療期以後,但是他們還是需要一個結構化生活環境
[ZH] 有時候這些機構就會把氣候轉介給他們,作為一些經驗生活的下一步
[ZH] 最後的訊息是一個普通的一種,網路
[ZH] 通常我們會從網路透過網路通訊息,但我們其實都很耐心
[ZH] 為什麼?因為最初的訊息可能更弱
[ZH] 當前面的資訊很弱,我們會增加了個性格的影響讓學生不適合我們的系統。
[ZH] 而且適合在住宅治療程中的重要性的重要性。
[ZH] 正確的學生在正確的環境中可以活動。
[ZH] 正確的學生在正確的環境中可以反對自己的問題,或是整個社會。
[ZH] 第四個的話有的學生是透過網路自己找到我們的
[ZH] 那對於這類個案我們會很謹慎
[ZH] 因為這類個案他們前端的篩檢資訊比較不完整
[ZH] 因為就可能是其他機構或是醫院轉接來的
[ZH] 所以會有一些適配不良的風險
[ZH] 因為在這種住宿環境裡面適配度很重要
[ZH] 因為合適的環境適配性很好的話可以對孩子很有幫助
[ZH] 但是不合適的環境的話反而會讓個案和整個這個群體帶來負面的影響
[ZH] Who could name the four referral sources that we typically use at TELOS?
[ZH] Who could name all four?
[EN]  Go ahead.
[EN]  One for the educational consultants and the state of business.
[EN]  And the site of study.
[EN]  Excellent, well done.
[EN]  Okay, let's keep going.
[EN]  Okay, before they become a student, so let's say the referral comes to us.
[EN]  Do we simply say, great, send them to Utah?
[EN]  Absolutely not.
[EN]  We do a lot of screening.
[EN]  One of the most important things we do happens at the very beginning of treatment.
[EN]  We spend approximately hours and hours, maybe even up to a week, assessing the student over the phone, making sure that he's a good fit.
[EN]  Our goal is to understand, who is this young person?
[EN]  What does he need?
[EN]  Why is he struggling?
[EN]  And what kind of treatment is actually going to help him?
[EN]  We want the whole picture.
[EN]  Whenever possible, we want psychological testing before admission.
[EN]  Why? Because we want to understand the student's cognitive strengths,
[EN*]  cognitive weaknesses, learning profile, and potential diagnostic picture.
[EN*]  But psychological testing is only one piece of the puzzle.
[EN*]  We also conduct our own comprehensive clinical psychosocial assessment.
[EN*]  And Drew actually went through that today with the clinical wheel.
[EN*]  and we go deep we look at okay who can name them all six clinical wheel
[EN*]  all six what do we look at go ahead
[EN]  true they actually listen to them biological factors yes
[EN]  Hard wiring, cognitive strengths, excellent. You grab a book. There you go, my love. This is all yours. There you go. Well done. Well done.
[EN]  I think it's the only translation of this part. Translation? Needed? No.
[EN]  Now, okay. Okay, so yes, the clinical wheel. When we assess, we're looking at the student through six pieces of the lens. Biological, hardwiring, learned behaviors, characterological trauma and environmental factors. Well done. We want to know about peers, technology, substance use, family, school. We're trying to understand not just what the student does, but why.
[ZH] 去瞭解,彌清說這個人是誰,他需要什麼,造成他現在有掙扎的核心原因是什麼,怎麼樣的一個治療方案才可以對他有幫助
[ZH] 然後除了就是我們可能的話會去取得他的心理學衡見,那除此之外我們還會進行就是剛剛講到最厲害的六大領域的這個評估
[EN*]  So, we need to understand what students have now,
[EN*]  but to look at the reasons behind them.
[EN*]  Now, the student himself is the expert.
[EN*]  We talked to previous therapists, psychiatrists,
[EN*]  schools, parents, and other treatment professionals,
[EN*]  we gather as much historical data as possible but here's something important the most important
[EN*]  information comes from the student himself and his parents because nobody knows the student's
[EN*]  internal experience better than the student and nobody has watched that young person develop over
[EN*]  18 years better than his parents so assessment isn't simply something we do to a student it's
[EN*]  is something we do with it.
[EN*]  Typically, it takes us about three to five weeks
[EN*]  when we have enough information to begin developing
[EN*]  and implementing a meaningful treatment plan.
[ZH] 那資訊來源就會是學生本人跟他的家長
[ZH] 因為沒有人是比學生本人更清楚他自己的感受
[ZH] 然後也沒有人可以比他的父母更瞭解他這18年來的這個成長軌跡
[ZH] 所以評估不是我們單方面對學生做的事情
[ZH] 而是我們和學生共同完成了一個合作的過程
[ZH] 那通常大概在第三到第五週的時候
[ZH] 我們就可以收集彙整出我們足夠的資訊
[ZH] 然後開始來訂計劃
[ZH] 要怎麼樣給他個別的計劃
[ZH] 每月每月,都會有精神科醫師,重視精神科醫師,這次是關於獨立的療程。
[EN*]  Every residential program has three core services that they are offering.
[EN*]  So once we've established the students' appropriate fit and the work begins, every residential treatment offers these three.
[EN*]  Residential, that's room, board, and supervision, they live there.
[ZH] 他們住在那裡,學生學生是在藝術的學校,可以獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獲獄職業。
[ZH] 考慮這些像是三腳的鞋子。如果是弱,鞋子掉了。
[ZH] 我們看一看各個的一種在各個的深度上的確認個案適配以後呢,我們就會展開改變的工作。我們的服務是有分成三大類。第一個是日常生活還有住宿支援,因為孩子就是住在我們的宿舍裡。第二個的話就是課業學習的部分。第三個是專業的臨床治療。這三個專案就像是一個三角的凳子一樣,是缺一不可。萬一有一個倒下來的話,那整張凳子就會壞掉。
[ZH] 現在我們先講到房間的房間,房間房間的房間。但之前我們進入那個環境,有一個重要的問題。尺導是一個重要的問題。尺導是一個大小的地方。在TELOS,每個大小的房間設計是10個學生。我們將來一個大小的工作。為了一個大小的工作。因為人口的工作。因為人口的工作。如果有多大小的工作,我們將來一個大小的工作。
[EN]  At Telos, each dormitory averages approximately 10 students, and we allocate approximately
[EN]  one staff member for every four students. Now, why so much staffing? Because individual
[EN]  attention matters. If you put too many students into one team, something happens. The individual
[EN]  treatment needs of students begin to get watered down. 10 students is already a significant
[ZH] 人類,診療、歷史,相關,與治療的需要。
[ZH] 當體療變得更大,
[ZH] 學生的能力更加深入了更加困難。
[ZH] 我們的目標是不只是擁有學生,
[ZH] 我們的目標是認識他們。
[ZH] 那我們現在講的第一項是廠生活和住宿的服務
[ZH] 這個規模我們會控制在很小
[ZH] 我們在TELOS每一個宿舍
[ZH] 每一棟宿舍只收十個學生
[ZH] 而且每四個學生會配三個工作人員
[ZH] 就是很高的師生比
[ZH] 那為什麼師生比會這麼…
[ZH] 誒,這說的厲害吧
[ZH] 很高的師生比
[ZH] 因為個別化的關注是很重要的
[ZH] 如果這個團隊人數太多的話
[ZH] 需求還有服務的品質就被稀釋
[ZH] 十位學生其實就已經包含他們很複雜的特質、狀況、還有需求
[ZH] 所以我們的目標就會把這個師生比方這麼高
[EN*]  Now, residential, the residence, is much more than just room and board.
[EN*]  Imagine moving 50 adolescent boys into one neighbourhood.
[EN*]  Different personalities, different diagnoses, different levels of maturity.
[EN*]  Someone has to teach them how to live together.
[EN*]  Now, residential mentors become teachers, coaches, role models, crisis managers, conflict mediators, and sometimes even surrogate parents.
[EN*]  The residential environment never sleeps, it operates 24 hours a day.
[ZH] 生活培託老師扮演的角色就很多元
[ZH] 他們是生活導師,也是他們在生活中正向的榜樣
[ZH] 也是危機處理者,也是衝突調解人
[ZH] 他們甚至可以說他們像是代理婦女一樣。
[ZH] 學生們等待、一起吃、一起吃、一起練習、一起結合、一起結合的事。
[ZH] 甚至睡覺也變成療癒,因為診斥不是我們學生們做的一件事,
[EN*]  isn't something we do to students, it's something they practice every hour.
[EN*]  Now people often ask me, what happens if a student gets angry? Wonderful! Now we have something to teach.
[EN*]  Residential provides hundreds of teachable moments every week. Those moments rarely happen in a therapy office.
[EN*]  It happens during breakfast, during chores, during homework, during recreation, during fights and conflicts, that's where mentors become invaluable.
[ZH] 我們生活在一起的話就會不斷的有適合給予教育意義的這些時機點的產生
[ZH] 這些時機點其實很少會真的發生在智商市裡面
[ZH] 它其實更常出現在吃早餐、做家事、語言互動的真實瞬間
[ZH] 這就是生活陪跑是為什麼這麼重要不可取代的地方
[ZH] So that's course service one, Residence, Root Board Supervision.
[EN*]  Now core service two, academics. I know you guys love your academics, you love your education. Here's how it works at Telos. School begins every morning at 8am, Monday through Friday. Unlike most schools, our classrooms average only six students. Could you imagine that? Six students in a classroom.
[EN*]  Why? Because many of our students have ADHD, executive functioning challenges, learning disabilities,
[EN*]  they're on the spectrum, maybe they're depressed or anxious, traditional classrooms simply overwhelm them.
[EN*]  Small classes allow teachers to individualise instruction and respond to the student who is actually sitting in front of them.
[ZH] 那許多的學生是有ADHD執行功能博弱,學習障礙、自閉、憂鬱、焦慮等等
[ZH] 那傳統的大班環境會讓他們覺得沒有辦法負荷
[ZH] 所以小班制可以讓老師特別做到個別化的教學,然後也可以跟學生做的環境
[ZH] 現在我們的學校是有一個A-B的專案
[ZH] 所以在乘八個課每天,學生會有四個課
[EN]  Monday, periods one through four, Tuesday, periods five through eight, Wednesday, one through four, Thursday, five through eight.
[EN]  Each class lasts approximately 80 minutes.
[EN]  This allows for deeper instruction, fewer transitions.
[EN]  Remember, processing kids don't do well with transitions.
[EN]  for students with executive functioning challenges, reducing the number of daily transitions often improves focus and reduces stress.
[ZH] 常常增加了、重點和減少壓力
[ZH] 我們在T-Low是採用A-B課表
[ZH] 每天只上四門課
[ZH] 週一到週三是一個版本
[ZH] 週二、週四是B版本
[ZH] 每節課是80分鐘
[ZH] 這樣的話可以深化教學內容
[ZH] 然後也可以讓學生減少一整天課堂要去轉換跑班的這個頻率
[ZH] 因為對於執行功能有障礙的學生其實減少轉換次數也可以提升他們的專注力還有減輕他們的教育
[EN]  We build capacity before increasing demand.
[EN]  One of the educational philosophers surprises parents.
[EN]  We intentionally reduce academic volume.
[EN]  Not expectations, but volume.
[EN]  Why?
[EN]  Because many of our students have spent years drowning.
[EN]  If we simply pile on more assignments, we recreate failure.
[EN]  Instead, we first teach organization, planning, time management, self-advocacy, emotional regulation, and study habits.
[EN]  Only after these skills strengthen do we increase academic demand.
[EN]  Our philosophy is simple. Build capacity first, increase expectations second.
[ZH] 那我們有一個比較獨特的教育理念會讓大家聽了可能會很驚訝
[ZH] 就是我們會刻意降低課業的作業量
[ZH] 那這不表示我們降低標準只是單純減量而已
[ZH] 因為許多的學生來我們機構前都是在學業裡面會很挫敗
[ZH] 所以如果只是繼續讓他們出很大量的作業的話
[ZH] 只會讓這個脆弱感加深
[ZH] 所以我們比較優先著重的是陪伴建立他們的組織規劃能力
[EN*]  Some focus on horses or equine, some on wilderness, some on substance abuse recovery. Our niche is called Neuro Fitness.
[EN*]  Speaking of Eurofitness, I need to stand and stretch.
[EN*]  Guys, we've sat down for a long time.
[EN*]  Feel free to stand up.
[EN*]  Take a stretch.
[EN*]  We'll do our own Eurofitness.
[ZH] OK,所以家庭經常會驚喜,我們送他們一個派對方,他們需要帶來一個車子,一個衣服,一個穿布,一個穿布,一個穿布,一般的穿布,一般的穿布,一般的穿布,一般的穿布,一般的衣服。
[ZH] 很多孩子問,為什麼醫療館需要所有的衣服?因為我們訓練更多,我們訓練頭,我們訓練頭。
[ZH] 那在學生,到我們機構前啊,我們會寫一張行李清單給家長,然後家長看到會覺得很驚訝
[ZH] 為什麼我們要準備腳踏車安全帽,背心,游泳衣,湧勁,還有腳踏車服
[ZH] 為什麼這個TILOS會要我們準備這些裝備,那答案是我們不只是在鍛鍊大家的身體,更是在鍛鍊學生的大腦身經
[ZH] 我們把神經提示的概念整合到我們的體育課裡面,所以在我們的體育課上,學生不止打來,我們把神經提示的概念整合到我們的體育課裡面。
[ZH] 我們把神經提示的這個概念整合到我們的體育課裡面,所以在我們的體育課的學生不只打來,我們把神經提示的這個概念整合到我們的體育課裡面,所以在我們的體育課的學生不只打來,我們把神經提示的這個概念整合到我們的體育課裡面。
[ZH] 所以在我們的體育課學生不只打籃球,他們還要進行耐力運動訓練
[ZH] 我們每一季會要求他們去挑戰鐵人三項,就三鐵,然後半馬,還有長途腳踏車比賽
[ZH] 那比賽本身並不是目標,而是resilience,就是這個復原力,韌性才是
[ZH] 現在一項一項每年輕人發現是,他們的身體能夠多於你的心心想起初心的信心。
[ZH] 有些學生說自己,我不能做,然後他們結束了第一半的馬賽,
[ZH] 那一句話永遠會失去世,信心是賺的,不給予。
[ZH] 那來我們Tilos的青少年他們常常會發現說
[ZH] 他們比自己想象中還要厲害
[ZH] 就是你身體可以做到的事情
[ZH] 其實比你一開始預設的要強大很多
[ZH] 所以很多學生剛來Tilos的時候會說我做不到
[ZH] 可是當他們就是親自到達馬拉松的終點線的時候
[ZH] 他們就再也不會再說我做不到這個句子了
[ZH] 就是自信其實不是靠別人給的
[EN*]  Well, they become therapeutic as well.
[EN*]  Most adolescents already know how to waste time.
[EN*]  Gaming, marijuana, scrolling social media, doom scrolling, sleeping all afternoon.
[EN*]  We aren't trying to remove recreation, we're trying to redefine it.
[ZH]  We're trying to redefine it
[ZH] 到了週末也沒有閒著,我們就給他們休閒治療,把休閒也變成一種治療,就是有一些青少年他們來到機構前就過得很沒有,就是在殺時間,他們會打電動啊,吸大麻,或是劃社群媒體,或是睡到下午之類的,那我們並不是要剝奪他們的休閒時間,而是要重新賦予休閒的健康意義。
[ZH] so the idea is to replace old habits
[EN]  Now, because UTAR offers incredible outdoor opportunities, our seasons shape our recreation.
[EN]  In the winter, we ski. We're only 25 minutes away from the Sundance Ski Resort.
[EN]  In the spring, we mountain bike. In the summer, we fish. In the fall, we rock climb.
[EN]  Every season introduces another healthy identity.
[EN*]  Let me tell you about a student that I worked with personally. His name is Carson and he's from San Francisco. Now he identified himself as a skateboarder, a marijuana user, anti-authority, counter-culture. Rock climbing wasn't even on his radar.
[EN]  But over time, something changed. He discovered climbing. And you know what? Today, he leads climbing expeditions throughout Southern Newtown. We didn't simply eliminate marijuana. We replaced it with purpose. That is recreation therapy.
[ZH] 可是在我們的陪伴下,他接觸了攀巖
[ZH] 那他就找到了人生的目標感
[ZH] 那現在呢,現在的Carson他會帶領團隊在南遊他州去主動去攀巖探險
[ZH] 所以我們很高興我們不只幫他借大麻
[ZH] 更用這個人生的新目標取代了原來的空虛
[ZH] 這就是休閒治療的意義
[ZH] 現在,不僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅僅
[EN]  has a theme, Monday and Wednesday are paid activities, students earn spending money based
[EN]  on how well their house functions, how clean it is, are they good at teamwork, are they
[EN]  emotionally safe, Tuesday and Thursday they still have activities but it involves no money,
[EN]  We intentionally teach adolescents that fund doesn't require spending.
[EN]  Friday, my favorite, is service.
[EN]  We go to food banks, community projects, volunteer organizations.
[ZH] 比如說每個禮拜一
[ZH] 我們會要求大家
[ZH] 根據自己的宿舍整潔度
[ZH] 團隊合作等等表現
[ZH] 來賺取自己的利用錢
[ZH] 那週二週四是
[ZH] 強調不花錢的活動
[ZH] 就是讓孩子體驗說不用花錢
[ZH] 也可以享受快樂的一些活動
[ZH] 那週五是我最喜歡的社會服務日
[ZH] 我們會帶孩子前往食物銀行
[ZH] 或是一些社群志工的機構服務
[ZH] 那因為就是
[ZH] 服務他人其實也是一個
[ZH] 這也是一個治療自我中心過剩或是內耗的一個面量
[ZH] 現在你可能會問,當時會有療程嗎?
[ZH] 每週我們會有個人療程,家庭療程,群組療程,醫療程式,診療程式,診療程式
[ZH] 那聽了那麼多大家可能想說那真正的therapy
[ZH] 可能大家腦海中那種要到醫生室裡面那種治療什麼時候會出現
[ZH] 那我們也有的,我們每週都會讓孩子接受臨床專業服務
[ZH] 比如說有團體治療,然後有個別心理治療,然後有家庭系統治療
[EN*]  Monday through Thursday we do groups. Some teach dialectical behavioural skills, others teach emotional regulation, focus on relationships, others process real struggles occurring that very day.
[EN*]  Students quickly realize I'm not the only one struggling. That realization alone is therapeutic.
[EN*]  And then we have family therapy. Once each week, individual therapy.
[ZH] 那包含了比如說辯證行為治療
[ZH] 情緒調節
[ZH] 還有也會帶孩子就是當天梳理
[ZH] 梳理當天發生的一些人際衝突
[ZH] 那孩子會發現
[ZH] 事情發生的時候原來不是隻有我一個人會覺得痛苦
[ZH] 那這樣這一份同理心其實本身就具有療癒力
[ZH] And then we have family therapy
[ZH] Once each week, individual therapy
[ZH] Once each week, family therapy
[ZH] 我們除此之外還有每週一次的個別心理治療,還有每週一次的家庭系統治療,會透過線上進行,我們希望父母不是整個治療計畫的旁觀者而是可以主動參與,因為我們非常需要家長的參與。
[ZH] 現在來講一個問題,當我們決定是否有學生的學生是否終了?
[EN]  Now, here's an important question.
[EN]  When do we decide if a student is finished?
[EN]  Not simply because a certain number of months have passed,
[EN]  not simply because the student wants to go home,
[EN]  and not simply because his insurance authorization ends.
[EN]  The student discharges when the treatment goals
[EN]  have been substantially completed,
[EN]  when there's been a significant decrease
[EN]  decreasing psychiatric symptoms.
[EN]  And when we see an increase in adaptive, and when we see an increase in adaptive behaviors, in other words, we're looking for evidence that the student can function differently.
[ZH] 另外一句話說,我們在尋找證明
[ZH] 學生能夠應用不同的方式
[ZH] 還有一個很關鍵的問題就是
[ZH] 怎麼樣可以決定學生已經有資格畢業了
[ZH] 不是說看他住了幾個月,也不是說他想要回家
[ZH] 結案的標準是我們治療目標已經實質達成了
[ZH] 想要改善症狀已經下降了,然後也具備充足的適應行為,它可以運作得很好,這樣才是我們的標準。
[EN*]  students who can function beautifully at TLOs, we want students who can function beautifully
[EN*]  without TLOs. The real test is whether the skills developed here transfer into life. Can
[EN*]  he regulate himself? Can he be responsible? Can he navigate relationships? Can he make
[EN*]  healthy decisions? Can he return to his family and community with a different set of behaviors?
[ZH] that is the measure of successful treatment
[ZH] 那我們給孩子設的終極目標是他可以把能力轉移到其他環境中也生活得很好
[ZH] 我們不只期待孩子在TELOS表現優異
[ZH] 我們需要看到的是他離開TELOS以後還是可以生活得很好
[ZH] 有這樣的獨立性
[ZH] 那可不可以再沒有人輔導和監督的狀態上調節情緒
[ZH] 承擔責任、處理人際關係、做出健康的選擇
[ZH] 這才是我們衡量的標準
[EN]  Well, our relationship with the family doesn't necessarily end on a discharge.
[EN]  For up to 60 days after discharge, the family can work with an aftercare specialist.
[EN]  The purpose is acclimation because going home can be harder than people expect.
[EN]  At Telos, there are routines, schedules, staff, teachers, therapists, structure.
[EN]  Then suddenly, the student's home.
[EN]  The aftercare specialist helps bridge that gap.
[EN]  One of the primary goals is to make sure the parents and the student are aligned around future boundaries and expectations.
[ZH] 就是在結案之後,我們還是會有一個追蹤專員去持續關心這個孩子
[ZH] 那協助他的家庭在常規啊 界限啊 責任之間建立公司
[ZH] 才可以確保說這個孩子從我們的機構
[ZH] 本來是很高度解構化的
[ZH] 他回家以後還是可以很順利先接過渡期
[ZH] 接回去他原來真實的家庭生活
[ZH] 所以誰改變學生
[ZH] 人們經常問我
[ZH] 哪個部份改變學生
[ZH] 問題是沒有的
[ZH] 學生改變 因為職員一起工作
[ZH] 住宅訊息是甚麼
[ZH] 學生確定 醫院考慮
[ZH] 醫院考慮 醫院考慮
[ZH] 理論 理論 支援
[ZH] 每個觀察都重要
[ZH] 有時候會有人問我說
[ZH] 到底哪一個TLOS的部門
[ZH] 對學生改變貢獻最大
[ZH] 那我的答案是 大家都不是單打獨鬥的
[ZH] 學生可以改變
[ZH] 就是因為我們有跨專業的團隊
[ZH] 緊密合作
[ZH] 我們的住宿生活陪考師他發現生活上面的問題
[ZH] 我們有一個很強大的教學團隊可以去驗證教學觀察
[EN*]  So let's go back to our 16-year-old boy, he wakes up, he gets his breakfast, he goes to school, he exercises, he attends therapy, he has a conflict with another student, a staff member helps him process it, he completes his homework, he goes rock climbing, calls his parents, he gets frustrated, he irradiates himself and goes to bed.
[EN*]  And tomorrow he does it again. That's resolution treatment. The repetition is the treatment. We are waiting for one magical therapy session. We're creating hundreds of opportunities for the students to practice being different.
[ZH] 每一次的實踐生活就是最好的治療
[ZH] 所以並不是某一次的諮商物談會發生的奇蹟
[ZH] 其實就是我們每天在衛函創造很多次數百次練習的機會
[ZH] 讓他們成為更好的自己
[EN]  It simply isn't therapy and it simply isn't school, it is the intentional engineering of an adolescent's daily life.
[EN]  Because eventually therapy ends as the school, residential ends, aftercare ends, and what remains is the lifestyle they have learned to live.
[EN]  Shae Shae.
[EN]  I think that's what I'm saying. It's not just a job, it's not just a job, it's not just a job, it's a whole way to provide the daily life of life.
[ZH] 也不是學校的補救教學
[ZH] 那是一個全方位的衛青少典提供日常生活的系統
[ZH] 那因為總有一天就是不管是什麼治療會結束
[ZH] 課堂會結束 機構生活也會結束
[ZH] 後續追蹤也會結束
[ZH] 最後留下來陪伴孩子的是他們真正有學會
[ZH] 變成念化的生活方式
[ZH] 謝謝大家
[ZH] 好的 謝謝各位
[ZH] 那剛剛大家已經參觀完這六十了
[ZH] 那我不好意思說有機會的話可以真正實地走一趟
[ZH] 但是我相信在今天的分享裡面
[ZH] 大概從各個專家帶來的經驗
[ZH] 得到很多新的學習
[ZH] 讓我們可以重新再審視
[ZH] 我們如何更好地去幫助我們的孩子們
[ZH] 那我想臺灣少實話這件事情
[ZH] 在世界排名大概是
[ZH] 沒有其他的國家可以跟上我們了
[ZH] 所以我們要珍惜每一個我們的孩子
[ZH] 不管是心理健康、身體健康